connaissez le principe de la kiss cam et
ouais bonne et on dirait qu'il est 22h49
il ya encore des sur pays aura des
surprises et des enfants cet enfant sans
fin alors donc des kinder soit tombé
dessus
regling je vais faire passer la caméra
dans le public
si la kiss cam s'arrête sur vous et
votre voisin vous lui faites un petit
bisou sur la bouche car aujourd'hui on
veut de l'amour à sur la joue dans le
coin qui peut plus foufou à vous de
décider
c'est être libre c'est partout c'est
parti jusqu'à
[Musique]
alors c'est qui est sûr qu'ils savent
[Applaudissements]
oui bah oui mais il est parvenu à gommer
terme était dans l'écran s'il vous plaît
abba embrassez-vous les deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est bardé alors sur kiss of art est
sûr qu'ils se sentent à l'aise et on en
trouvera lui alors ah ouais ouais non
c'est la voilà à est pas mal et j'en
vois c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez bien tous les deux mais
c'est pas c'est pas nicolas ça c'est
nicolas c'est nicolas c'est pas tiffany
à côté si c'est ça bon ils sont venus
cédera-t-il fans et nicolas ont le saoût
l'amour de thé play le pays mais ce que
je crois que j'ai c'est bien tiffany
nicolas ce que je crois que c'est un
message pour vous de regarder et
j'aimerais une manif mais là on a aussi
une petite s'appelle milliards j'envoie
un message non papa et maman
si fanni est niée color ce sont les
meilleurs parents m'ont même temps que
les tissus nous font plaisir
malheureusement ils ne prennent jamais
de temps juste pour eux des papas mamans
ce soir on a quelque chose de très
important à vous dire on vous aime créer
et avant de vous quitter
on a une dernière question à vous poser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lundi mais les gars vous êtes ma musique
les deux quelle beaucoup france soir
vous êtes très très beau sarah tiffany
merci d'être là bien moi j'aime bien mon
match et rien dans mon chat a bien tuer
tuer tuer tuer partie de nana les chéris
ça fait combien de temps que vous
connaissez tous les deux nicolas 16 en
saison pareil tous c'est lourd dans
douze ans nous en 12 ans josé il ya
toujours un descartes il ya toujours le
mec qui croient qu'il a connu sa meuf
avant que son cas n'était qu'un autre
mais qu'un nicolas et les familles que
vous êtes en disant vous êtes mariés ou
28 ans et non pas du tout non vous avez
trois enfants c'est ça 4 et ben je
rajoute un cinquième c'est comme ça
c'est la faune raccord vous avez cellule
5e c'est ce à quoi c'est vrai ouais ah
ouais alors vous avez maylis maeva
médina et mélia médias qui les a bien
répondu exactement que les aime et que
des fûts nicolas et tiffany vous avez vu
les enfants ou une dernière chose à vous
demander
oui
alors je vous dis on s'est dit bon pour
la dernière chose comme c'est très très
important
on s'est dit qu'il fallait absolument
pour les phases venir ce soir et maylis
maeva et mises à jour
[Applaudissements]
sa chérie tu le fais un bisou et vous
êtes magnifique l'e3 alors les chéris
qu'est ce que vous avez à demander à
maman et un papa
alors je vous le dis il y à maylis neuf
ans maeva 7 ans et medina 6 ans et ça
lui sourit oui alors qu'ils demandent à
papa et maman
alors c'est toi ma chérie c'est la
grande c'est maylis oui messieurs voici
maintenant un métier plus haut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourrait faire rentrer oui match chili
est arrêté et a été formidable
il est le dieu ça a été direct
formidable est contente et heureuse
alors si chéri joe dit j'aurais fait
rentrer quelqu'un qui n'est pas en masse
clover c'est vrai qu'on fasse rentrer
jessica
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là jessica je vous en prie
merci a vous de me recevoir sur votre
plateau ça nous fait très plaisir est
très content de vous avoir des gens
voudrais remercier allah méchali qui
vous a offert les alliances et jessica
vous êtes créatrice et directrice de la
société sublime et je crois que j'avais
quelque chose à dire à nicholas pettit
fait c'est ça ça fait six ans que j'ai
ouvert un showroom de 500 m² à herblay
la boutique sublime et donc je crée des
robes ce qui est mon plus grand plaisir
et ce soir votre histoire m'a beaucoup
touché donc j'ai décidé à tous les deux
vous offrir bas votre costume et votre
robe de mariée
une petite rigolote latine rigolade
parce que jessica toute sa famille
d'organiser le mariage puisque votre
papa francis offre la salle autres
maintenant veronica et traiteurs et vos
adversaires maxime qui est gênant et son
frère sébastien et photographes
et oui tout ça tout le mariage est
organisé par jessica qu'on peut
ça vous le savez on va on va toujours au
bout au bout ou au bout des choses vous
le savez alors je vais verser kahina de
time to go parce que qui dit mariage dit
voyage et le voyage de noces on va vous
offrir
il est incroyable puisque vous allez
partir à meudon
vous allez partir dans un hôtel 4
étoiles tout compris mais vous savez où
agents ibar
[Applaudissements]
vous savez on est évidemment si jessica
merci je vous en prie avec les hyènes
hôpital
[Applaudissements]